- [Voiceover] So, I have three
different functions here.
I know they're all called f,
but we're gonna just assume
they are different functions.
And, for each of these, I
want to do three things.
I want to find the zeros.
And so, the zeros are the input values
that make the value of the
function equal to zero.
So, here it'd be the t values
that make f of t equal zero.
Here, it'd be the x values
that make the function equal zero.
So, I want to find the zeros.
I also want to find the
coordinates of the vertex.
And finally, I want to find the equation
of the line of symmetry.
Line of symmetry.
And in particular, to make it
a little bit more specific,
the vertical line of symmetry,
which will actually be
the only line of symmetry for these three.
So, pause the video and
see if you can figure out
the zeros, the vertex,
and the line of symmetry.
And I'm assuming you just did that
and now I am going to attempt to do it.
And if, at any point, you get inspired
pause the video again and
keep on working on it.
The best way to learn this
stuff is to do it yourself.
So, let's see, so let's
first find the zeros.
So, to find the zeros, we can set
t minus five squared,
minus nine, equal to zero.
So, we could say t ... for what t's does
t minus five squared,
minus nine, equal zero?
Let's see, to solve this, we
could add nine to both sides.
And so we could say, if
we add nine to both sides
the lefthand side's just
t minus five squared.
The righthand side is going to be nine.
And so, if t minus five squared
is nine, that means that
t minus five could be equal to
the positive square root of nine
or t minus five could equal
the negative square root of nine.
And to solve for t, we could
add five to both sides,
so we get t is equal to
eight or t is equal to,
if we add five to both sides here,
t is equal to two.
And just like that, we
have found the zeros
for this function because if
t is equal to eight or two,
the function is going to be zero.
F of eight is zero and f
of two is going to be zero.
Now, let's find the vertex,
the coordinates of the vertex.
The coordinates of the vertex.
So, the x coordinate of the vertex,
or sorry, I should say the
t coordinate of the vertex
since the input variable here is t,
the t coordinate of the
vertex is going to be
halfway in between the zeros.
It's going to be halfway in between where
the parabola, in this case,
is going to intersect the x axis,
or the t axis, I keep saying x axis,
the t axis for this case.
So, halfway between eight and two.
Well, it's gonna be the average of them.
Eight plus two, over two.
That's ten over two, that's five.
The t coordinate is five and five is
three away from eight
and three away from two.
And, when t is equal to
five, what is f of t?
What is f of five?
Well, when t is equal to five,
five minus five squared is just zero.
And then, f of five is just
going to be negative nine.
And this form of a function,
this is actually called
vertex form because it's very
easy to pick out the vertex.
It's very easy to
realize, like, okay look,
for this particular one, we're
going to hit a minimum point
when this part of the
expression is equal to zero
because this thing, the
lowest value it can take on
is zero cause you're squaring it,
it can never take on a negative value.
And it takes on zero
when t is equal to five.
And when that's, if this part is zero,
then the f of five is
going to be negative nine.
So, just like that, we have
established the vertex.
Now, we actually have a lot of information
if we wanted to draw it.
So, if we want to draw this function.
I'll just do a very quick sketch of it.
Whoops.
So, a very quick sketch of it.
So, that is our t axis, not our x axis,
I have to keep reminding myself.
And that is my,
let's call that my y axis.
And we're going to graph
y is equal to f of t.
Well, we know the vertex is at the point
five comma negative nine.
So, this is, t is equal to five
and y is equal to negative nine,
so that's the vertex right over there.
And then, we know we have zeros
at t equals eight and t equals two.
So, t equals eight and t equals two.
Let me make that a little
bit in, t equals two.
Those are the two zeros.
So, eight and two.
And so, just like that,
we can graph f of t,
or we can graph y is equal to f of t.
So, y is equal to f of t is
going to look something like
let me draw it a little
... something like that
That's the graph of y is equal to f of t.
Now, the last thing that I
said is the line of symmetry.
Well, the line of symmetry is going to be
the vertical line that
goes through the vertex.
So, the equation of that line of symmetry
is going to be t is equal to five.
That's really just the t
coordinate of the vertex.
That defines the line of symmetry.
Let's do the other two right over here.
So, what are the zeros?
Well, if you set this equal
to zero, if we say x plus two
times x plus four is equal to zero,
well that's going to happen
if x plus two is equal to zero
or x plus four is equal to zero.
This is going to happen if we
subtract two from both sides,
when x is negative two,
and if we subtract four
from both sides, or when x
is equal to negative four.
As we said, the vertex, the
x coordinate of the vertex,
is going to be halfway in between these.
So, it's going to be negative
two plus negative four,
over two, so that would
be negative six, over two,
which is just negative three.
Negative three.
And when x is negative
three, f of x is going to be,
let's see, it's going to be negative one
times one, right?
Negative three plus two is
negative one, and so times one.
So, it's just going to be negative one.
There you have it.
And the line of symmetry is
going to be the vertical line
x is equal to negative three.
And once again, we can
graph that really fast.
So, let me,
this is my y axis.
See everything is
happening for negative x's,
so I'll draw it a little
bit more skewed this way.
This is my x axis.
And we see that we have zeros
at x equals negative two
and x is equal to negative four.
So, negative one, two, three, four.
So, we have zeros
there, negative two, be careful.
Negative two and negative four.
And the vertex is at negative
three comma negaitve one.
So, negative three comma negative one.
Make sure we see that, so this is
negative one right over
here, negative one.
This is negative two,
this is negative four.
And so we can sketch out what the graph of
y is equal to f of x
is going to look like.
It's gonna look something like that.
That is y is equal to f of x.
Let's do one more.
Hopefully, we're getting the hang of this.
So, here, to solve x squared,
plus six x, plus eight
is equal to zero, it will
be useful to factor this.
And so, this can be written as, and if you
have trouble doing this,
I encourage you to watch
videos on factoring polynomials,
What adds up to six and when you
take their product is eight?
Well, four and two.
Four plus two is six and
four times two is eight.
So, is equal to zero.
And then, this is actually
the exact same thing
as what we have in blue right over here.
These are actually the
exact same function.
They're just written in different forms.
And so, the solutions are
gonna be the exact solutions
that we just saw right
over here and the graph
is going to be the same thing
that we have right over there.
So, same vertex, same line
of symmetry, same zeros.
These functions were just
written in different ways.